- Bert, you still are
meeting people after shows?
After these theater shows?
- You should.
- Tell me how you've been able to do it
and not lose your mind.
And not not do it, because last weekend
I was in D.C. and I was like
"I don't wanna be touched
by people right now"
"I don't wanna do it".
- I don't normally get touched,
people take their shirts off.
- [Nikki] Yeah I know.
- Get a sweaty underarm
on top of your shoulder.
(laughs)
- Dude the skin tags just ...
(rolls tongue)
Oh here we go.
I had one guy one time takes his shirt off
and he grabs me and I'm like
"Bro you are on fire" and he's like
"Yeah I've got a pretty bad fever".
(laughs)
I was like ...
I go "You're sick?"
and he was like "Very sick".
I was like "Dude, am I going to get sick?"
he goes "Probably"
I was like "Why are you doing this?"
he goes "I wasn't gonna miss this"
"for the fucking life of
me, are you kidding me?"
- [Nikki] No!
- That's so rude.
- Dude I got sick as shit for that guy.
(upbeat music)
- I wanna ask you about
when you first drank
after Sober October.
How good did that feel?
And how bad did that
feel the next morning?
Like how hard did you go?
What did you do?
- The first drink I had ...
You know as crazy as I ...
Like I mean, I'm just
measuring this by last night
because last night was
the kind of drinking
that I dislike, where like
I'm just on a fucking
plane and I'm just ordering
doubles after doubles after doubles.
- [Nikki] How are you here?
- And I'm like, oh it's
Mickey Mantle Gene.
- He sluts.
- That first weekend I drank
it was all of a sudden like a brand new,
it was like being 18 again and drinking
and going "I just need one drink"
and I'm feeling tired
and I'm gonna go home.
And I was really measured
and then I flew home
and then my wife threw
a birthday part for me
and I had a ...
That was Sunday and so it
was like a full bender Sunday
and then we did Sober
October and I blacked out
during that podcast.
- I have no recollection of the last hour.
I remember we all went to dinner,
I know that I paid, I have
no idea what the bill was.
I don't know if I tipped.
- [Nikki] I hate that feeling.
- [Tom] That's the worst feeling.
- I woke up the next
morning and I said to Tommy
I was like, I would have
been equally as surprised
had I've been chained in a basement
versus waking up in my bed.
Both of them I was like, how
the fuck did this happen?
- Oh man, how often do you get that drUnk?
- Not often, I mean I
think Sober October ...
I mean we smoked a blunt,
I never smoke blunts.
- I love blunts.
- Oh I really enjoyed the blunts as well.
- Yeah that's really fun.
- We drank a whole bottle of whiskey,
we drank a bunch of beers.
We were trying to bench press,
I think Rogan pulled his leg,
pulled a muscle in his leg.
We were trying to bench press 225.
I'm fucking 46, why am I benching 225.
- That's three of me.
- Yeah.
And so or a little bit less of me.
(laughs)
- But don't you feel
like after you have been
so sober and so clean
it's like you got so clean
and then it's like going backwards.
You know that feeling of like
oh I did this and now ...
- I'll tell you what's
interesting, remember those people
that go "I eliminated
all food and then slowly"
"reintroduced things back into my diet"
"to figure out what I was allergic to."
Alcohol is directly
connected to my anxiety
and I think I always knew
that but I didn't realize
how hand in hand, what kissing cousins
alcohol and anxiety are.
Because I was getting on planes and flying
stone sober and being cool with it
and having no panic.
But man the uneasiness that
alcohol does to my stomach
I get to the airport and I am like a mess.
And then I'm like "Well fuck
I need a drink to calm down."
- It's a cycle.
- Yeah for sure.
- Jeez.
- I think it's ...
Because I've been dabbling
with the idea of maybe
drinking again and I'm just like ...
- No don't do it.
It's so not worth it.
- And it's a depressant.
And I'm already depressed.
Why am I going to flirt with something
that literally makes you depressed?
- Mine is, I have the worst
acid reflux from drinking.
Acid reflux so bad, like I
have one glass of something
and it's like ...
(retching)
- Sleeping is the thing
that I value more than
anything else right now.
I slept so good during
the month of October.
I slept so good.
Now he's the difference, I slept
really good during October.
The last night, wasted, wasted.
Got into my hotel room at two, made a nice
double T dose of soda.
Killed it before bed and this morning
I woke up with the most beautiful dream
that I've ever had in my life
and I hadn't been dreaming during October.
I had just been sleeping.
I had a dream where I
was sitting next to ...
Have any of you guys
ever smoked cigarettes?
- [Ian] I love 'em.
- Sitting next to a
beautiful woman on a dock
smoking a cigarette and I
was enjoying the cigarette.
I was getting the buzz from
the nicotine in the dream.
I'm getting the buzz from the nicotine.
- Your stomach doesn't hurt.
- Pulling it hard as shit.
And we're recapping all
my dreams from the night
me and her, like this is our rap, right?
We did a great show, we
had a bunch of dreams.
We robbed a bank, we
had to organize all my
pants from Trip Flip.
We did all these things
and then at the end
she says "One more cigarette?"
and I went "Yeah" and I knew
I wasn't going to smoke again
but I just hit it really hard
and then I said
- You have cerebral palsy.
- I haven't kissed someone
who's smoked a cigarette
in so long, I wonder if I can taste it.
And she said "I don't know
we should try kissing"
and I went "Okay" and we started kissing.
I woke up and went "What a
beautiful way to start my day."
I literally was like "I'm back baby"
and I was like splashing water on the face
time to go to SiriusXM.
We got a long fucking day B man,
try to strap it on big boy.
- We're back with the show.
Bert, was were you just about
to ask me about my drinking?
- So when you talk about drinking again
what part do you miss?
Because I'll tell you the parts that I ...
- I'll tell you exactly the part.
- Okay go.
- I miss this Nikki, when
someone walks in a room
like you're drinking at the
Comedy Cellar back table.
I miss seeing someone and going
"Oh shit there he is".
(laughs)
That drunk, I miss that Nikki.
I don't get that excited
about seeing people anymore.
That's two drink Nikki.
Kind of like rocking out
like feeling the music
and just excited.
I miss that.
- You don't get from weed
like that a little bit?
- I will find certain
times that it helps me
but it's different with drinking.
You know what, I finished
Joe Rogan's podcast
and I stole a kombucha from his fridge
right afterwards because they get so much.
And I grabbed one of the alcoholic ones
and I chugged it in the car
and I got like one drink drunk.
And my friend who was sober was driving me
and she goes "Oh my god, Nikki"
Carlisle, she was like "That's alcoholic"
and I was like "Oh my god"
and I just thought I'm
going to enjoy this.
I turned the music up
I was like I get to be
drunk for the first time
in seven years and probably the last time.
And I had the best time
like singing to music.
That's the drunk I miss Bert.
- You don't miss the ...
My favorite drunk is family's asleep,
I'm in the man cave
and I'm gonna put the lights out
I'm gonna light some candles
and I'm gonna get my
speedo, maybe a cowboy hat
and I'm gonna just go through
the entire Smiths catalog
and listen to The Smiths
and get weird as fuck.
- ♪ To die by your side would
be a heavenly way to die. ♪
- I love that one.
- Dude.
- Your daughter wakes up
by accident, goes
downstairs like "Uh, dad?"
- Daddy what are you ...
- My wife came out one time
and I had watched a movie about the
new age, when new age came to Britain.
- Oh yeah.
- And I just got ...
And I was obsessed, I'm on repeat.
I must have listened 100
times to the Talking Heads.
One of their first, I
forget which one it was,
Serial Killer?
- Psycho Killer.
- [Bert] Psycho Killer.
- Yeah that whole album
is fucking incredible.
- It really is, that's my
favorite kind of drunk.
- Okay yeah, music.
Getting weird by ...
I do miss that too.
- I miss just turning my phone off,
drawing the shades and
just drinking by myself
and alienating all my friends.
- Yeah Ian has such a
problem with drinking
that the things you miss get real ...
They're not even fun weird.
They're just sad weird.
- I miss like waking up in the hospital
and then proving to myself
that it won't happen again.
(laughs)
- That's the kind of drinking I miss.
- You do.
You're always like ...
What would happen right
now if you had a drink?
What would become of your day?
- 40 drinks later.
- I mean I wouldn't stop, I would end up
finding cocaine and then I would just ...
- Yeah that's the problem
for a lot of guys.
- End up getting with a
prostitute, wasting my money
and being like "This
dumpster looks comfortable".
(laughs)
- Yeah I got rejected at
a glory hole yesterday.
- I don't miss that, I
don't miss that at all.
- Wait is that true?
- [Bert] Wait what?
- I'm so glad, I just kind of teased it
because I wanted to see if he wanted
to talk about it on air,
because I forgot to ask him
and he just gave me the heads up.
You got rejected at a
glory hole yesterday.
- Wait at a glory hole or
at Glory Hole like the bar?
- At a glory hole.
- A glory hole.
- How do you ...
Did they flick it?
What happens?
- [Ian] No.
(laughs)
- They swipe the dick tip.
- Swipe left.
- These are not the
dicks we're looking for.
(laughs)
- They just start pushing it back in.
Like they're trying to get one of those
fake snakes back into the can.
- They blow on it, yeah.
So, explain that.
- Walk us through this.
What made you end up going to a glory hole
in the first place?
- Start by where it's at,
because I'd love to swing by.
(laughs)
- You wanna after this?
It's quite an experience.
It's on 21st on 8th
- Can girls go?
- Yeah yeah, well they
don't like fish but ...
- Dude you were like two
blocks from my apartment
getting rejected.
You gotta come over after that.
I know you were feeling sad.
- Yeah.
- Okay so what led you there?
- I don't know I've just
been real horned up lately.
- You're seeing somebody
though also right?
- [Ian] Yeah she knows.
- But like she.
- She knows about
the glory hole.
- She wasn't going to fulfill
what you wanted in that.
- Right, right.
And more, like with the drinking thing
like I don't miss getting drunk.
I miss waking up in a
fucking bag of trash.
I miss the craziness of it.
- [Bert] Chaos.
- Yeah.
So like I was getting off
more on the fact of like
walking in and having
some 6"4 Dominican guy
hate my dick and me being
like "Yeah let's do this".
Like that was what got
me off, rather than like
I'm going to get my dick sucked.
- I like that experience too,
I like weird experiences.
- The dangerous thing of
me trying to get a blow job
while a guy's mopping up
come in the staff next to me.
- [Jade] Beautiful, yeah.
- So you go in.
- [Ian] So I went in.
- Wait how do you know that this exists?
Is there like an app or like ...
- No you like cruise around.
- You just walk around looking
like Ian and they find you.
- [Bert] Sorry sir, that's an eyehole.
(laughs)
- Oh my god, yeah how do you?
You just know?
People are like hey there's a hole here.
- This mustache is attractive
for shit like this.
- Sir that's a man hole,
we're down here doing work.
(laughs)
- Trying to get some work done myself.
- You just start sticking
your dick in everything.
- Trying to fix the L drain.
- You gotta stick your
dick in a lot of holes
before you find it.
- Sir that's a bird house.
(laughs)
- Sir are you trying to
make a deposit in the bank?
- I just keep sliding my dick through.
- That's a bee hive.
(dolphin squeak)
- Wait that's a dolphin.
- [Jade] That's a hole.
- Get off me.
- Ow!
- [Bert] That's a dolphin.
- Sir that's my vagina.
- Oh disgusting.
- Not today.
- Sir that's my vagina.
- Only when I'm in the mood.
- I want a man to suck my
dick through your vagina.
(laughs)
- Tapping on the vagina.
- Okay those are good.
Walk us through ...
- So I ...
(laughs)
Call me when that vagina turns into a man.
So I went in and this
fucking guy when I walked by
went "Mhmmm" and I was
like "Alright I'm in".
So I went in, I kind of looked around
and you know ...
- [Jade] What kind of hole's that?
- It's like a very eye contacty thing.
- It's a store, right?
- It's in the back of a store.
All the porno shops you see, in the back
they have these fucking stalls.
- Oh a porn store.
It's not like a best buy, okay cool.
- No, no, you gotta go
to the Salvation Army
and ask for Ted.
- [Jade] Ew, Ted.
- So I went in and you know I
thought this guy was whatever
and then I was standing ...
- You thought what guy was whatever?
Where are the guys standing?
I don't understand.
- They stand outside the
stalls and you've gotta
kind of like look and be like
give like a look of like "What's up?"
- Cut to a sketch of me going
"So what are we in line for?"
(laughs)
- "You're next".
"Oh sweet, oh you guys
are going to let me cut?"
- A dick just pops out of a hole.
- Is this Apple returns?
(laughs)
- So you know who the guys is.
Isn't it supposed to be
you don't know who is it?
Isn't that the hole
point of the glory hole?
- Sometimes you can go into a thing
and there's just a treat waiting for you.
But other times you make eye contact.
- And you go,
"do you want to make out
with me through a wall?"
- Why don't just blow each other then?
Why the hole aspect?
- Because it's like a ...
- The smell of cedar.
- I didn't invent it, I'm just using it.
- You wanna like size him up,
see what his mouth looks like.
- Yeah, I'm not a heathen.
- But really, the wall
does seem stupid then.
- Yeah I don't understand the wall.
- Why not just get a booth and
blow each other in a booth?
- Right.
- What's the deal with
the wall separation?
- It's kind of nice because
once it's over, it's over.
- Yeah that's true.
- It's like, there's
no awkward eye contact
you're like fucking thank God that's over.
- And then you just finish and you leave
and you never see them again.
- Is it a thin wall?
- It's like ply.
- It better be.
Paper thin.
- If your dick didn't fit all the way in.
- It could take like half
an inch off your dick.
- It could be like this thick of a wall.
- And then half an inch
means a lot to men, I think.
- Oh I'd be using that
excuse the whole time.
I'd be like "Look, this is a thick wall".
"You can't see it on
your end, it's very big".
- "It's a thick wall".
"Got a thick wall here".
- But wait how tall is the wall?
Can you see?
Is the wall like this short?
- No no.
- No these are Trump walls.
- Wait so they don't even exist?
Holey shit.
- That's what you should
do, you should start
lobbying to put glory holes in the wall.
(laughs)
- That would bring more people out to vote
if we voting booths were glory holes.
- Wait I wish the wall was just this tall
so you're just peaking over it.
- Just making direct eye contact.
- You cannot see each other when like ...
But you're on your knees
so you would be able to see them anyway?
- No you're not on your knees.
- There's a pew.
- It's a pew.
It's a confession booth.
And if you want to get
to heaven, you've got to
suck father's pee pee.
- [Jade] Ew, got so real.
- So you don't kneel?
- No, you can kneel,
you don't have to kneel.
There's a little chair.
- You know what would be a
perfect blow job giving thing.
- Who cleans that chair?
- Is like the massage
chairs that you sit in
in the mall and you lean forward.
That would be a good blow job chair.
- Oh yeah it would.
- [Bert] Oh they have that porn.
- Oh I know Bert.
- Go to milking.com.
- Oh my god milking.
- What the hell is milking?
- Milking, it's like a glory hole
but you're laying on your stomach
and a woman's just on
her knees just milking.
- Wait, I have a dream
that I go to a sauna
and I sit and underneath there's someone
eating me out through a hole.
- That's my dream.
- [Jade] Yeah like I want that.
- By dream, you mean fantasy?
- No I mean reality.
- [Nikki] Like you want that to happen.
- Day dream.
- Glory hole for a woman.
That's what I want.
- There would just be listening.
- While I'm in like a sauna place.
- [Bert] Oh my god.
I was in a sauna in Miami.
When you used to stay across the street
at one of the places,
they had a sauna in there.
And Leanne was coming to visit me,
she was pregnant with Isla
and I walked into the sauna
and this girl walks in totally naked
into the sauna.
I have shorts on.
Totally naked but with
shell top Adidas on.
- Wait what?
Tennis shoes?
- Yeah and no socks.
- Ew.
- And she was like.
- [Jade] Whore.
- She was like "You don't have
to wear your pants in here"
and I was like "Oh yeah, I'm
probably just going to wear"
"my pants" and she was like
"Well I'm not wearing clothes"
and I was like "Cool".
And we're sitting there for a while
and I'm so uncomfortable.
And she's like "Do you have a room here?"
and I was like ...
- Jesus.
- And I was so creeped out
that she wasn't wearing socks.
- [Jade] I think it's disgusting.
- Disgusting.
- [Bert] Oh fucking horrible.
- Those shoes are ruined.
- And I was like "My pregnant
wife's on her way here"
and then I just got out.
By the way, there's nothing
better than having sauna cock.
Sauna cock is ...
- What's sauna cock?
- Sauna cock, are you serious?
- Sounds like a sound system.
- [Tom] Like a toothbrush.
- Something that's going
to sponsor the show.
- You can stick it on your mirror.
- [Ian] Have you guys
ever used sauna cock?
- Sauna cock is basically when you're just
you're in a sauna for like 30 minutes
and your dick, all the
blood is going everywhere
and your dick is just huge.
- That's why I wanna get
eaten out on a sauna.
Cause you get sauna clit.
- Sauna clit.
- That sounds like a toothbrush.
- And it does get like a little swollen.
- You're soaking up
all the heat and stuff.
- All the blood just
rushes down to your clit.
Wait can, p.s. this is not a plug
but can that vibrator
that you recommended me
the Womenizer has changed my life.
- [Nikki] Thank you.
- It is a flesh light for
your clit, it's crazy.
- It sucks your clit.
- What?
- Oh you haven't heard of this?
- [Jade] It's amazing.
- It's changed the game with orgasms.
I didn't know I can squirt.
I didn't know until I had the Womanizer.
- I'm afraid that I get this from my wife
and then sub myself out of
the game all of a sudden.
- No no no, it's different.
It's a different feeling.
- Men can learn from it,
I've been talking about this on stage.
If you go down on us, stop
the rubbing your face in it
or whatever you do.
Suck our clit.
- Sneezing in it.
- Coughing in it.
- Blowing your nose.
Whispering in secrets.
- The alphabet thing, it's bull shit.
- Singing a song to it.
- The alphabet sucks.
Licking is fun.
- What's it called?
- The Womanizer.
- How come Louis came up?
No I'm kidding.
By the way sorry, I'm
sorry, I shouldn't do that.
- I have a code right now that you can use
it's JADE20.
- [Nikki] What?
- Yeah all caps, JADE20.
- How the fuck did you get a code?
- Because she commented on
one of my Instagram photos
like "Get the Womanizer" so
I just texted them directly.
I was like sending me one,
I'll review it on my story.
- Oh my god.
- So they sent me one and it's been ...
Because you know what it
is, it doesn't feel like
it goes inside you.
You feel like you're
fucking it, in a weird way.
- Is this it, the white thing?
- Yeah but get the black or red.
I regret getting the white one
because it's too clinical looking for me.
- Oh wow.
- Too like futuristic.
- [Bert] The Womanizer Starlet.
Womanizer Premium.
- It looks like a kazoo.
- [Bert] Do you wanna
go Womanizer Premium?
- I'm like getting excited
thinking about this toy.
- Leanne doesn't like sex toys.
I've always tried to
do that and she's like
"Why would I do that when you're here?"
and I'm like "I don't know
maybe for when I'm not here"
"I don't know".
- This one.
Because you know what it is?
It happens quickly too and then I giggle.
- [Nikki] Me too.
- I get hysterical.
- It is a different kind of orgasm than
you've experienced
before if you don't know
this kind of suction orgasm.
- But also it took me
a while to figure out
how to use it.
I was like, where does this go?
- It's, the vagina is not user friendly.
I'm confused by it.
- [Bert] No shit.
- My own.
- Try not having one and
trying to figure it out.
- I know I feel for you guys.
- Figure it out on the fucking
like you're defusing a bomb.
- The only manual's passive aggression.
- You're in 9th grade
trying to figure it out.
Wait I thought it's this high?
It's lower?
- It's way higher than
you think it will be.
- I thought it was directly under.
- I still don't know where I pee from.
I still don't know.
- Same it just comes out.
- No idea where I pee from
it is like a leak in a cave.
- Yeah shut up.
- I was 30 when I found
out there was two holes.
(laughs)
- Wait like vagina and a butt?
Or a vagina?
- I thought it just
came out of your vagina.
- Oh your urethra.
- Poured out of your everywhere.
- I'm just finding that out.
- Yeah your urethra.
- It really does seem to
like creep from a crevice.
You know when you look at a cave wall
and there's water streaming down like
where is this water coming from?
That is exactly what it's like.
It's very confusing but the Womanizer
you definitely need to suck that clit
- I agree and I'm like hey
you guys send me two more
because I wanna give one to my mom
and my sister so.
- It makes sense because I
watched a video ages ago.
(laughs)
- That taught you how to eat pussy.
Like it was an instructional
video by Nina Hartley.
She's like an old porn star
about how to eat pussy.
I remember watching it and she said
treat the clit like you
would your tiny penis.
If your penis was very tiny,
what you would want done to it
do exactly that.
And it's an insane thing to say
because guys don't want
to see gay or whatever.
But give us a blow job on our clits.
- It is a blow job.
It is a tiny blow job.
(sucking)
Like literally like that.
- [Nikki] Yeah it's really ...
So that's my advice to you if you go down
on a girl this weekend.
Latch onto that thing like a barnacle
on an old boat and don't let go
until the captain sprays you off.
(laughs)
(upbeat music)